hello everyone and welcome to the
semi-finals of the Champions Chester
finals it is Fabiano Carana versus
Magnus Carlson and this is the fifth
game of their match which means it's an
Armageddon game uh after the four four
games that were really really
interesting if you guys have the time
watch the entire match live or the
recording of the live session uh because
it's really action-packed it started by
Magnus winning game one then Fab
retaliated in game two took the lead in
game three and then Magnus won on demand
in game four uh forcing Armageddon and
as us usually in Armageddon you have to
bid your time it's better to play with
the black pieces because you only need a
draw to to win the match and I I think
so far pretty much no one ever outbid
Magnus he always as he is objectively
the the best player in the world he will
allow himself to play with as little
time as possible I think once he even
outbeat Hikaru by like a second or or
two seconds that's how he he good how
good he is at this bidding war thing uh
but yeah let's check it out Fab has the
white pieces and he opens with E4 and
Magnus replies with C5 you can see 8
minutes 54 seconds for him and 15
minutes for Fabby so I think Magnus been
like 8 minutes and 57 seconds H we have
Knight to F3 Pawn to E6 and now Pawn to
D4 going for the open Sicilian captures
captures and now Pawn to A6 Magnus
challenges Fabby to aan Sicilian where
it's um uh a bit of a different setup
you you start out with your pawns
without the knight ever being on F6 so
the white Pawn on e4 is not hanging and
Fabby has um quite a lot of options to
choose from like he could even go for
the maroi bind setup which is um uh
which a lot of people enjoy playing but
he challenges Magnus to a more direct
approach Knight to C3 Queen to C7 and
now Bishop to D3 we have Knight to F6 uh
and queen to E2 castling here is by far
the most popular Fabby wants to surprise
Magnus a little bit Queen to E2 uh we
have Pawn to D6 and now Pawn to F4
Knight B to D7 so of course you know
that the Knight is coming to C5 to
pressure the bishop and the Central Pawn
and pawn to G4 a pretty standard way of
challenging the Knight here you want to
play G5 and then H4 H5 and attack the
black king as you are probably betting
that the black king will Castle King's
side Knight to C5 by Magnus and now Pawn
to G5 challenging the Knight here Knight
F to D7 and now Pawn to A4 first
stopping Pawn to B5 Bishop to E7 and now
Pawn to H4 now the is nicely defended
you might even consider something like
F5 very soon and there are a couple of
games where um this position has been
reached but interestingly in the
positions I've even found one game where
this position has been reached but it
was white move so somehow through all of
this back and forth action Magnus won a
move somewhere because there is a game
where this exact same position happened
and white played H5 where whereas here
we we have black on the move and Magnus
plays Pawn to B6 so it is now as of move
12 that we have a completely new game
and okay of course he wants to F C to
the light Square Bishop get the Rook
into the game Fabby continues
development Bishop to E3 and now Bishop
to B7 we have Pawn to H5 continuing to
play on the king side uh Rook to C8 uh
of course you will want to put more
pressure on that C file and at some
point of course you will execute B5 to
to break through Fab goes Rook to G1 he
wants to open up the G file but Magnus
stops that he plays Pawn to G6 himself
uh Rook back to H1 now Fabby wants to
open up the H file and now Pawn to E5
challenging the Knight with have H
captur and G6 uh trying to sacrifice the
Knight here but of course that would be
um pretty silly because if if you take
the Knight here then Bishop captures on
D4 and you have all sorts of problems
here The Rook is hanging if you move the
Rook then the pawn advances uh and
you'll just get demolished here but an
interesting uh idea could have occurred
in the game because here we have F
captures on G6 and now uh what do you
play here well Fabby went back Knight to
F3 because the Knight is saying but he
should have stuck to his guns here and
play Pawn to F5 the problem is now uh if
Magnus plays e captures on D4 and it's
not really a problem it's the best move
e captures on D4 and Bishop captures
attacking The Rook it is a little bit
different even if uh Knight captures on
D3 happens okay C captures on D3 you you
remove an attacker let's say Rook to G8
uh F6 and now uh once Rook captures on
H7 happens that's pretty much it uh even
if you repeat something uh well there's
really nothing to repeat you can play H5
because you really don't want to see
Rook captur us on H7 now even Rook to F1
threatening F7 check and if Rook to f8
now you will take and you are now very
happy with your position for example
captures Queen captures an F1 King will
capture here you'll play Rook C1 you
have nice action on the queen here uh
the Knight can move the df6 is well
under White's control so this would be
winning for Fabby but he went back
Knight to F3 and now e captures an F4
now Magnus will trade as much as
possible before starting an attack on
the queen side Bishop captures Knight
captures on D3 with check C captures and
now Knight to E5 uh making it a bit um
problematic for Fabby to now create some
sort of an attack and while Bishop
captures on E5 is the best move and
Fabby probably knows it uh it doesn't
give him much of an attacking position
so he wants to keep material on the
board he plays Bishop E3 prepares to put
the bishop on D4 uh we have castles Now
by Magnus and now The Rook is no longer
on h8 and the H7 point is nicely
defended by the king and now Knight to
D4 going after this E6 Square Queen to
D7 defending and now Queen side castles
and here King to D2 is the way to go
with Queens side castles uh you allow
Magnus to start the attack right away
because the Knight on C3 is spinned and
he does so by playing Pawn to B5 and
okay a captures a captures you have to
move the king king to B1 uh Now Pawn to
B4 we have Knight to A2 and now comes
Pawn to D5 and here we reach a most um
unpleasant position for Fabby because
there's not all that much you can do
here uh problem is if you if you just
capture this uh then White's position is
just terrible there's not much you can
do here you can even shift the Rooks to
the a file the bishop is here the other
Rook can come to to the C file uh this
would be really bad but the critical
line to calculate is Knight to F5 and
look at what is possible here G captures
an F5 now you're going to play Bishop to
D four okay you want to win your piece
back and after Bishop to D6 you will
play G6 and now after Knight captures on
G6 you'll play Rook D to G1 and look at
how uh beautiful this position is for
white of course it's still objectively
uh winning for black but you know with
little time on the clock uh maybe it's
possible to get something here the idea
is that after captures you will play
Rook captures and G6 check H captures
Rook to HH check now you will win the
white the black queen and after King T8
Rook captures on D7 and King captures on
D7 but still still it's two Rooks
against the queen and you have these uh
past pawns marching forward uh it's not
going to be easy for white to survive
this but maybe it was it was a little
bit better than uh what Fabby went for
uh he went for Rook captures on F on H7
which again is one of the engine's
recommendations but uh it doesn't offer
much King captures on H7 Queen to H2
with check King to G8 and now Rook to H1
uh here interestingly if you go after
the Knight it doesn't really do all that
much just Bishop to D6 and the queen has
to be traded you don't have time to get
the Rook into the attack you're going to
have to trade Queens here and after
Knight captures just Rook F3 and Black's
position is much better so here Fabby
threw in Rook to H1 he threatens
Checkmate on H7 but there is a move that
uh he probably missed and it is the move
that wins Magnus the game so feel free
to pause the video and try to figure out
a way out of this mess while I give you
a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations and realizing that
the two weaknesses can be dealt with one
move and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Bishop to D6
this is what Magnus played and now uh
Fabby really doesn't have all that much
the Knight is defended the dh7 square is
guarded uh what do you play here uh well
you could still go for Queen to h8 but
Queen to h8 is such a long disgusting
line that I absolutely will show it and
that that starts with queen to h8 check
King F7 now Rook H7 check okay you're
going to hide the King on E8 and now
okay you're you can win the black queen
but you will also have to give up your
own Queen but it is the best thing to do
Rook captures on D7 Rook captures on h8
and you even pick up the bishop on D6
but it doesn't matter because there's
Rook to H1 with check and now after
Knight to C1 there's Knight captures on
D3 piling up on the Knight here and you
will start losing material it doesn't
matter even if you play Knight E2 you
you bring another Defender to the Knight
uh look at White's position all of the
pieces are tied down to the defense of
the Knight on C1 and you can't uh even
defend it D4 you try to uh get the
bishop away from the defense of the
Knight and if Bishop D2 now you even
trade Knight captures Knight captures
and Bishop captures on e4 with check
King to A2 now Bishop to C2 controlling
B1 and B3 now you're threatening
Checkmate and once white stopped this
now you advance further Rook to D1 you
attack the bishop and once the bishop
moves just D3 with D2 will uh uh win you
the game it's possible to maybe play
something like Knight to B3 but still
just Bishop to B1 check King to A1 Now
Pawn to D2 and uh that's um that's all
there is there's no way to defend this
anymore if if if you capture the pawn
just Bishop D E4 with check King A2
Bishop to D5 with check uh and after
Knight to B3 blocking you will play Rook
to D3 and that's uh that's pretty much
it if you move King to B1 Bishop
captures on B3 with Rook D1 next uh it
it's game over so well uh White can
prolong I mean it's merely prolonging so
Fabby played Bishop to F4 he realized
that Queen to h8 will not yield the
Victory and now Magnus played Queen to
G7 which is interesting Queen to G7 is
the only not winning move for Magnus he
can play Bishop to A6 he can play D
captures on e4 he can play B3 H but
remember he needs only a draw here to
win the match so he plays Queen to G7 he
stops Queen h8 now he doesn't have to
calculate anymore and he says you cannot
uh beat me here so Faby does go Knight
E6 attacks the queen and the Rook but
there's also Knight to F3 attacking the
queen Here and Now Fabby does have some
choices here but none of them really
work as the bishop here uh has to be
defended the bishop is attacked twice uh
if you play Queen G3 then look at this
bishop captures on F4 Queen captures on
F3 and now there's this very nasty Queen
captures on B2 move uh just nicely uh
aligning the the queen with the rook and
also you will save the bishop so you
don't lose to too much material Bishop
to F4 will Bishop D5 will come with
check and okay even D4 you can play that
but now Rook captures on F3 and after d
captures on E5 D captures on e4 and the
pawn now will be too too powerful you're
also up the exchange so completely
winning another thing Fabby could do is
play Queen to H3 looks a bit weird
because you remove the defender of the
bishop here uh but after Rook captures
on F4 and Knight captures on G7 grabbing
the queen there's an instant draw Knight
to D2 check King will have to move to H1
as the C1 square is covered by The Rook
so King H1 and here Magnus easily gets a
Perpetual with Knight to D2 Knight to B3
checking action so uh Fabby had a a huge
problem here because he has to win he
cannot draw the game uh he plays Knight
captures and G7 and he just goes into a
losing endgame Knight captures on H2
Bishop captures on D6 and now Rook to F1
with check Rook captures Knight captures
and the real problem is also here uh you
cannot defend the Knight on G 7 the
problem is if you try to save it let's
say Knight to E6 then you fall to Knight
to D2 check King to A1 and now Knight to
B3 with check King B1 and D captures on
e4 uh where you have to decide what you
play H you either allow the the pawn to
March forward or or you capture here and
this is mate in one Bishop captures and
E4 is Checkmate or you allow the pawn to
survive but uh I mean what do you play
Bishop captures then the pawn comes to
D3 and uh well that's all there is not
much to be done here so after Knight
captures on F1 Fabby said all right I
have to uh leave the Knight stranded he
played Bishop captures on B4 and the
Magnus eliminates the lonely Knight of
the board King captures on G7 and now
he's up a full Rook so of course it's
completely winning Fabby played a few
more moves you know because it's you
know it's hard to resign after after
having a four game match against Magnus
and holding your own uh now you're just
dead lost and you will of course play a
few more moves D captures and E4 D
captures Bishop captures with check King
A2 and now Knight to E3 and he was in
this position on move 39 that Fabiano
corana resigned the game and with it the
first semi final match as is it is a set
of two matches so he will have a chance
to bounce back today uh so yeah like I
said if you guys have the time do watch
the entire show it's been it's been I
mean brutal I mean also game one where
Magnus just gives up the queen and he
has two two puns in a rook against the
Fab Queen Magnus was dead lost but then
Fabby made a mistake first he he gave
Magnus a drawing position and then he
also gave just a winning position but
both players with a few seconds on the
clock I mean it was pure Madness if you
have the time watch the entire thing
really you guys will enjoy it uh so yeah
that's the game I hope you guys enjoyed
it I would like to thank Robert arthu
and Sam's giant tortois farm the Night
Before Christmas good luck on law school
finals cam k v and Benjamin hyberger for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon continuing to
check up on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the Chess
World so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day and I will very soon announce my
Christmas tournament uh but very soon uh
see you
soon